but like i want to kind of give people
like a real idea of like how long this
journey has been for you because like
you were also
independently very successful
before
you and i met you had a following you
know what i'm saying like this [ __ ] is
very
it feels like
like
20 years in
yo for sure i realized how old i was
listening to you and cassie's podcast
when caskey who's a dude that's been
around for a long time now referenced me
as the first dude he did a song with
yeah and i was like i am [ __ ] old
yeah i was like it's happened i became
him i'm
yeah cassie's been around a long time
yeah yeah
so what was like you remember like what
was the first project what was that year
i came
i got released from jail the last time
that i had to do a bid in
2009
okay and i put out the 10 minute
freestyle which we were talking about
off camera that if my p.o asked i hang
drywall
which we still sell those shirts on
jellyroll615.com
and
i remember putting it on youtube
my dude had a flip cam chad arms yeah i
just was watching the youtube video like
two weeks ago yeah we didn't realize the
power of youtube now mind you i was
putting out mixtapes while i was in and
out of jail before that old school yeah
cd spindles you were part of this era
we're running around passing out five
dollars like straight off the spindle
handwritten jelly roll
right
so i did that and then my introduction
to the internet
was about 2009
and he filmed that 10 minute freestyle
and uploaded it
and it went
crazy
especially for that era because then me
and little white ended up doing pop
another pill because white reached out
to me right after i got out of jail
and then we did the snow project with
juicy j and dj paulin project pad and we
had all that history with 36 mafia at
that time
and all that stuff we were doing
and i remember me and little white has
shot to pop another pill video with mike
busey in panama city beach sean mike
busey this is back when
world star hip-hop was god
right
we submitted it to world star hip-hop
and i'll never forget this they said hey
man we only post videos that go viral
first time i heard the word viral and we
were like well define viral and in the
email back they said 30 000 views in a
week
on youtube that's it that's how you
still had to go to a desktop computer
and type in
www.youtube.com yeah you know what i'm
saying so it's like
it was in such it's infant stages that
they're we ended up doing 50 000 views
in three days so they put it on world
star
and that was the beginning of that
that was like one of my first eras you
know what i'm saying damn i feel like
post jail you don't count like the seven
mixtapes i did how long were you in jail
every time was a different amount of
time from 14 to 24 probably seven and a
half to eight years [ __ ] so just kind of
in and out
do a year come home for six months do a
year come home for four months dude it's
drug [ __ ]
everything from you know i don't know
i'm not
yeah i'm not proud of any of it it's
public information so well it's good
that you know yeah but everything from
gun charges to drugs to a robbery case
do you remember like uh what cuz you
know you know people like this i know
people like this that have potential
that are talented but for whatever
reason they just get stuck in that
back into jail it's the revolving door
of the judicial system like what was the
breaking point for you where you were
like nah this is enough i got to get my
[ __ ] on track it's so cool talking to
you because we know each other so
personally you know but it was my
daughter yeah bailey was born in 2008 so
one of those times where i was out of
jail i had gotten a young woman pregnant
okay and then bailey was born while i
was in jail
and in the old southern baptist term
that was my damascus road experience
where saul turned to paul
i'll never forget i was in like the gang
unit like the like worst dorm you could
be in in jail at the time [ __ ] because i
was just running the poker table and
gambling and not you know i was just
[ __ ] doing time
and the day they knocked on my door and
told me bailey was born i signed up to
go to the education unit try to get my
ged i don't know what just like i
scrambled out of nowhere i was just like
oh i got to figure this [ __ ] out right
now
and i ended up having to do like another
year but whenever i came home you know
it was a game changer that was it we
started off to the races
yo uh you're like uh you know i feel
like
the rock taps in with a lot of artists
that i happen to know but he really
[ __ ] with you it's my dude is that not
awesome the rock has been [ __ ] with
you like for like five six years now
that's crazy like he posts your [ __ ] all
the time all the time
he is just he's a nashville dude at
heart
loki he's like
he traveled so much as a child
that he has a lot of places he's really
connected with and by luck of the beast
nashville is one of them
so he really kind of connects to our
scene and culture
like he gets guys like me
and he told me earlier he was like yo
i know guys like you from nashville so
man you had this talk early like
nashville was kind of famous for that
white boy trap rap [ __ ] yeah it was like
uh yourself was haystack from hey for
sure nashville boy he was ahead of us
haystack kind of led the charge on that
and
there was so many you know we had a band
before haystack called rude awakening
chris taylor which is like an uncle or
cousin of ours me and my brother and
it's like well white's from nashville
little white's from memphis down the
street in tennessee it's all that kind
of you know
so he was like i get the culture of the
city he's like people won't get it at
first but trust me it'll it'll work yeah
because there was like this like
nashville white boy dope boy [ __ ] going
on that like like you said it was very
like you had to
be from there to really understand
like what kind of dudes you were at the
time for sure which is why we popped in
florida because florida had so many
white boys like that too yeah yeah yeah
so it's like when you went to st pete
you were just like it was a town full of
them yeah you know or largo or all that
stuff the old gasoline alley bar we
played down there back in the day the
thug crackers the thug crackers you know
what i'm saying you remember this so it
was like caskey cask there were so many
kids that was that that culture came so
like florida and
georgia the south especially just
immediately in the midwest indiana ohio
they love you in ohio oh dude it's like
first